carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
un placer saludarles desde nuestros
estudios en parís para este espacio que
nos acerca a la cultura y a las artes
les damos la bienvenida a este programa
donde les hablaremos de la actualidad
teatral la fotografía el cine y la
música francesa
el teatro planta cara a la epidemia de
coronavirus con la semana de arte en
avignon un mini festival teatral
organizado tras la anulación del
festival internacional de teatro 2020
conversaremos con alfredo bosco autor de
la impactante serie fotográfica guerrero
estado olvidado ganadora del premio visa
de oro humanitario que entrega cada año
el comité internacional de la cruz roja
en los estrenos de cine francés dos
exploraciones femeninas la búsqueda de
la identidad en adn y un encuentro en
forma de cuento azules de tual de página
en nuestra crónica musical natal y
olivares recuerda la fascinante
trayectoria y obra de la recién
desaparecida juliette greco la musa de
sant llama the pride
[Música]
comenzamos este carrusel de las artes en
avignon esta ciudad del sur de francia
es conocida por su prestigioso festival
internacional de teatro que debió ser
anulado en julio pasado debido a la
epidemia por el coronavirus pero este
mes se lleva a cabo una semana de arte
en avignon que rescata a algunas de las
piezas que debían ser presentadas en el
verano nos lo cuenta melissa ibarra
m
aviñón no se podía quedar sin su
festival ni siquiera en tiempos de kobe
sus organizadores abrieron los teatros
de la ciudad para una semana de arte en
avignon un mini festival de otoño bajo
estrictas medidas sanitarias y en
horarios que cumplen con el toque de
queda nocturno aplicado en varias
regiones de francia
[Música]
la semana del arte en avignon fue el
primer nombre del festival algo que se
sabe muy poco así que cuando tuvimos que
anular la adición 2020 el festival
pensamos que podíamos hacer un evento
retomando el nombre original del
festival se hacía en septiembre en esta
semana rescatamos siete de los
espectáculos que debían presentarse en
julio y cuyo tema era eros y tánatos así
que el amor y la muerte están muy
presentes esta semana en la que
resonarán las trompetas de vino back
complete papel de niño
la escena más emblemática de aviñón el
palacio de los papás no abrirá para esta
semana del arte en avignon las
representaciones se hacen en pequeños
teatros o de forma itinerante
[Música]
la situación es realmente complicada y
estamos trabajando en condiciones muy
difíciles tanto los organizadores como
los artistas y al mismo tiempo estamos
felices porque vamos a hacer teatro
esperamos que los artistas encontrarán
en esta catástrofe una fuente de
inspiración y que el público apreciará
aún más el valor de las artes escénicas
[Música]
del teatro pasamos a la fotografía este
año el festival de fotoperiodismo visa
pour l'image en la ciudad de perpiñán
hizo visible la realidad del estado de
guerrero en mexico a través de una
impactante serie fotográfica guerrero
estado olvidado es el nombre de este
foto reportaje con imágenes muy duras
sobre la guerra entre cárteles de la
droga carrusel de las artes fue la
encuentro del autor de estas fotos el
italiano alfredo bosco quien fue
galardonado en francia por este trabajo
el estado de guerrero en el suroeste de
méxico es una de las zonas de mayor
producción de amapolas del continente lo
que ha generado un sangriento conflicto
armado es lo que documentó el fotógrafo
italiano alfredo bosco en su serie
guerrero estado olvidado un trabajo que
le valió el premio visa de oro
humanitario que entrega el comité
internacional de la cruz roja
a todo el proyecto solo estado de
guerrero tran y comencé este proyecto
hace tres años en guerreros se libra un
conflicto muy distinto al de otros
estados mexicanos es una guerra interna
no solo del estado contra los grupos
criminales sino que estos grupos se
combaten entre ellos y esto ha llevado a
niveles de violencia dramáticos por otro
lado están las policías comunitarias que
son grupos constituidos para defenderse
de los criminales lo que pasa es que
muchos policías comunitarios terminan
entrando en el mercado ilegal de la
droga y se convierten en grupos
criminales
es uno de los dramas característicos de
mexico en el particular y guerrero el
nivel de corrupción y de infiltración
criminal es tan alto que las autoridades
locales o el jefe de la policía pueden
estar ligados a los carteles los
carteles
alfredo bosco también exploró en sus
fotos las repercusiones de este
conflicto sobre las mujeres y los niños
cercanos superséis dos tipos de
violencia que afectan a sectores de la
población como las mujeres se lograron
por un lado el feminicidio es algo muy
frecuente en una red pero las mujeres
también son víctimas de la violencia del
narco como miembros y comunidades
rurales que viven con miedo muchas han
decidido apoyar a la policía como pero
hay zonas en donde recientemente la
policía ha decidido administrar a los
niños algo que no había sucedido hasta
ahora así que se puede hablar de la
emergencia de niños soldado
por la represión iban bien y soldado
[Música]
a continuación nuestro bloque de cine
francés esta semana les presentamos dos
cintas protagonizadas por mujeres que
exploran realidades personales
familiares y sociales en la francia de
hoy llega a las salas de cine la
película adn de la directora francesa
maiwenn una vez más muy buen explora su
historia personal en adn la muerte de
mir
el abuelo de origen argelino desencadenó
una tormenta familiar y una profunda
crisis de identidad en su nieta
nerd
[Música]
y atrás
resolverás donde siente mejor en casa
servicio 15 para gente como mi familia
un muy buen directora y protagonista de
esta cinta explora aquí la relación
explosiva con una madre tóxica y una
familia complicada así como la búsqueda
de nuestras raíces de quiénes somos de
nuestro adn
este común amontonada emocional
[Música]
también entre los estrenos un cuento
protagonizado por la veterana actriz
francesa catherine frot en los zapatos
de un indigente llamada cristina bajo
las estrellas de parís cuenta la
historia de su encuentro con cilic un
niño de 8 años migrante perdido en las
calles de la capital francesa
[Música]
a mí
christina trata de huir de ese pequeño
polisón en su vida de mujer sin amigos
ni familia pero la compañía de su líder
mina por enternecer a christina quien lo
ayuda a buscar a sus padres
esta película de klaus de excel trae a
la pantalla grande la dura realidad de
la inmigración y de las mujeres
indigentes quienes representan casi un
20 por ciento de los sintechos en parís
y nos quedamos justamente en parís para
recordar a una de las musas de la
capital francesa juliette greco falleció
en septiembre pasado a los 93 años
dejando una huella inolvidable en la
historia de la canción francesa con su
sensualidad y su voz natal y olivares
nos habla de ella desde el emblemático
barrio parisino de saint german de para
él
[Música]
y limón
hay quien se llama dije nació la voz
suave y profunda de hecho ya vive con la
voz de la cantante francesa nació vivió
y también el sábado aquí su canción yo
limón escrita por leo ferré se escuchó
durante sus funerales y quedó impregnada
para siempre en las calles disfrazadas
de pelo
más
y su editor
[Música]
de
libertad en si es amor y empatía fueron
las reivindicaciones de julian greco
durante toda su carrera
la prueba aquí con esa canción de xavi
i
es mi hermano
ah
a mí me patrocinó
para ti
[Música]
desde habíamos una canción que ha sido
escrita un año antes de la revuelta
estudiantil de mayo del 68 a partir de
ahí siguen récords se convirtió en un
icono de la mujer libre después de haber
vivido la persecución de la segunda
guerra mundial
juliette greco siempre contó que había
perdido la palabra cuando era joven pues
bien a quien se llama de la tribu de los
intelectuales le ayudó a recobrar la
palabra así fue
[Música]
deja su voz como legado a la canción
francesa pero su mejor logro ha sido
extirpar la poesía de los círculos
intelectuales para devolverla a la calle
de ahí donde ella decía que venía
[Música]
pero
st
[Música]
gracias natal y olivares y nosotros nos
despedimos con la seductora voz de
juliette greco muchísimas gracias por su
amable sintonía cuídense mucho y hasta
la próxima
[Música]
de qué
y si fue
[Música]
no
es mío
[Música]
yo
eso
[Música]
[Aplausos]